freunde herzlich willkommen zu einem
neuen video ich stehe hier gemeinsam mit
fred wasser dem aller echten okay er ist
gerade gegangen sehr schade wir haben
heute etwas besonderes vor und zwar
machen wir bei freddy und auch bei mir
ein video in dem wir eine köstliche
mahlzeit bestellen und eine köstliche
mahlzeit von helau fresh kochen immer in
ihr kennt uns ja es wäre ein video von
uns wenn ich auch was bestellt werden
würde
ich mache jetzt meine bestellung fertig
dann bereite ich für uns beide vor und
dann wird getestet was wie abschneide
was geiler ist was besser ist machen
sich zuerst mal die bestellung geh dann
mal so lange macht es ja auch gleich mit
dir genau
und dann müssen wir gucken was besser
ist da ganz genau und selbstgemacht sich
mal ganz kurz vor ab bevor es richtig
losgeht helle max 50 das meint aber dazu
kommen wir später ich hatte schon mal
ein video mit hell of fresh gemacht und
ich habe eure kritik gesehen ich habe
sehr viele kommentare beantwortet ich
war das ganze ein bisschen zu positiv
was ich nachvollziehen kann rückblickend
ich muss aber dazu sagen ich selbst war
wirklich sehr geflasht also ich habe
'hallo' frächter ausprobiert ich war
wirklich legend begeistert einfach davon
und habe das ein bisschen der autor ich
rüber gebracht deshalb gehen wir das
ganze heute ein bisschen distanzierte
anteil hat und trotzdem bock drauf habe
gesagt wir fanden das richtig cool und
viele von euch muss man auch dazusagen
fand es auch sehr nice und haben auch
bestellt bei hello fresh jetzt wie
gesagt gucken wir als erstes mal welches
gericht wir quasi nachbestellen wir
haben hier die box erkennt dass er aus
meinem letzten video das ganze
verpackungssystem ist eigentlich echt
ziemlich smart also die box ist recycelt
das hier diese coole tasche ist
irgendwie auch recycelt die geben sich
wirklich sehr viel mühe und hier haben
wir wieder die rezeptkarten dabei wir
haben heute zum beispiel rauchige
süßkartoffel hirten käse parcours fand
ich sehr nice ist aber schwer
nachzubestellen das war generell ein
problem also hallo fleischgerichte nach
zuständen ist schon mal gar nicht so
einfach was aber wenn ich darüber
nachdenke eigentlich nice ist weil das
ist halt kein standards zeugs und in dem
sinne mag sie tatsächlich mit ricotta 5
und jetzt kommen wir zu dem gericht was
wir heute auch nach machen eine bunte
asia ball mit grünem spargel ich werde
also jetzt erst mal probieren etwas
vergleichbares zu bestellen
ich habe das ausgewählt weil ich
übertrieben bock auf spargel hatte
leider leider gibt es keinen spargel zur
auswahl
beim bestellen ist habe ich einfach mal
ballack genommen das spare am nächsten
ist radieschen sind drin karotten sind
drin er aber auch nicht
wie gesagt einfach ein bisschen
nachgebaut 11 gibt es das nicht spargel
war für mich wirklich entscheidungs
treiben erdnusssoße extrem geil ist auch
dabei so hab ich das ganze jetzt einmal
raus kostet elf euro wird alles carlotta
die bestellung ist raus jetzt heißt es
35 minuten die die zubereitung vor
diesem gericht dauern soll ich gucke auf
die uhr wenn ihr film um 50 muss das
ganze fertig sein der fed lasst uns
loslegen haben wir unsere zutaten einmal
spargel eine möhre eine limette eine
avocado mario was marty wildreis
mischung schwarzkümmel sesam sesamöl
erdnussbutter ehre dass hier wird
kritischer sein mario und teriyaki soße
und dann haben wir noch radieschen also
ihr seht schon ein paar frische zutaten
ein paar und verpackt und zu starten
natürlich auch ein paar sachen die
einzeln verpackt sind wozu ich aber
sagen muss roger so hätte ich nicht
zuhause sesamöl platz ist für mich
wirklich einer der major punkte ich als
fauler mensch der ansonsten wirklich
sehr häufig essen bestellt ich nutze mit
teriyaki soße brauche ich häufig nicht
auch für mich persönlich ist es sehr
nice zu wissen dass man halt nichts
wegschmeißen von dem essen weil ich muss
selbstkritisch anerkennen dass sich das
häufig mache ich muss aber auch auf die
uhr gucken heute bei wir haben rennen
mit der zeit auch mal vergessen 2
knoblauchzehen ich glaube dass uns am
ende des tages jeder für sich selbst
abwägen klar du hast hier ein bisschen
verpacken und zeigt dabei aber du wirst
halt nichts weg und das ist mir
persönlich wichtig weshalb lassen sich
mal loslegen die haben ja unsere
anleitung das kennt ihr aus dem letzten
video zunächst müssen wir mal reis
kochen 300 milliliter heißt es wasser
zum kochen bringen so bestellen als
erstes mal den herd aufzunehmen und das
sind ob wir fügen wir einmal die 300
milliliter wasser manchmal gar nicht so
viel ich bin wirklich ein reißen das ist
aber eine sache der sich könnte schwer
werden für hello fresh weil restaurant
reis ist halt wirklich sehr sehr wissen
ok dann kümmern wir uns nur das gemüse
wir schnappen uns unseren spargel hatten
ihn einmal auf das sind schon
ordentliche office ist es gerade
spargelzeit ja es ist fragezeit oder ja
also das find ich schon mal nein das ist
ja so nahe ist es auch ein freundlicher
uschi spargel weil also sparen ist ja
schon ein bisschen teurer so wasser
kocht schon das geht ja so flott mit der
induktion unglaublich gegen ein bisschen
runter mit und gebe den reis hinein
deckel kommen aus dem topf drauf salzen
natürlich noch das wasser noch nie
wir lieben seid also ich schneide und
ein bisschen ab so wie es ein rezept
steht und dann stehe ich ein wenig das
war nix macht die augen zumacht deine
beiden zeigefinger und mittelfinger
ausstrecken nun überreiche ich dir den
besten spieler aller zeiten viel spaß
max
guck dir an wie das runter raesfeld ok
bester fehler geil also leute bevor wir
jetzt weiterkommen einmal ein shameless
klagt falls ihr euch selbst überzeugen
wollt von head of trash ja bewusst in
kot helau max 50 und die zeit das ist
kein spaß auf die erste box sechs
portionen 15 euro normalpreis sind 40
euro aber ihr habt altfetten rabatt drin
und keine lieferkosten wenn ihr meinen
court benutzt deshalb falls ihr noch
kritisch seid so falls ihr denkt jetzt
will ich mal selbst aus hessen dafür ist
dieser code da
damit ist hessen könnte also der apartes
gestaffelte kriegen und 25 euro auch die
erste box dann 15 dann 10.5.8 ganz sonst
geht mir auf jeden fall den spargel
geschält relativ grob also man muss das
ja nicht zwangsläufig machen drei sieht
sehr gut aus limette waschen bereitet
sie limettenschale abbaus richtigen
ultra fresh so werden jetzt ein bisschen
die testet am 1
es riecht heftig lecker muss man sagt
ich liebe zitronen oder limettensaft und
es riecht möglich automatisch ja hallo
oder max 5 wir haben lehnte auch eine
ganz komische art und weise geführt ich
glaube recherche unterstützt nicht wie
ich diese limette geviertelt habe der
reis kocht vor sich hin hat das war
schon ganz gut absorbiert dann verlieren
wir die avocado was sagt der avocado
schon zu der avocado sie fühlt sich
relativ gut an wird ein zwei kleine
dellen aber wenn sie jetzt gut ist bei
avocado ist schon eine wissenschaft für
sich muss man dazu seien absolut sicher
schauen wir mal rein er hatte der
avocado post eine bessere auswählen
können aber sie sieht eigentlich sehr
nett aus aber sehr zu 23 druckstellen
vom transport halt die schneide ich
jetzt einfach großzügig weg aber avocado
und auch wirklich mutig finde ich dass
die avocado reinpacken
ich schneide jetzt mal hier in schöne
streichen aber ansonsten sieht die reif
aus ja darauf treffen jetzt ein wenig
von
limette weil jetzt sehr ergiebig sehr
sagte das ehrlich krank das jetzt so ein
drittel vom saft habe manchmal früchte
da geht gar nix und manchmal welche das
übel ist klasse die sind dann so holt
sich ja genau die hunde gucke mal bei
unserem reis 3
sie haben es nicht an klebt jetzt
benutzen wieder den besten spieler der
welt was schon sagt borst recht sachlich
karotte von hinten abschneiden und grob
reiben spargel braten kommt dann wollte
ich doch mal die plattenfirma heißt
salat zubereiten jetzt brauche ich
angeschüttet dort geben wir den limetten
abrieb hinein zwar klienten abrieb
karotte den saft aus einer limetten
spalte sich wieder rauskommt ist
wirklich krank angespannt aber das is
crazy dann kommt daran eine prise zucker
dann haben wir noch unsere radieschen so
also wie radieschen nämlich auch mit in
die schale die fahne ist jetzt schon
schön heiß her gehen wir ein bisschen öl
reine spargel war es schon fast zu groß
dafür ne aber es passt es kann man hier
wir schnappen uns unseren see samt gehen
den hier hinein und ich hab den
knoblauch einfach mal ein bisschen klein
wir haben gerade schwierigkeiten die
presse zu finden und er muss gleich dazu
spargel treppchen an der saison leistet
vom schwarzkümmel nämlich ein bisschen
weniger wobei der sie verschönert so
sieht kümmel aus zum schluss geben wir
da einfach mal unseren knoblauch dazu
gibt mir ganz noch ein bisschen mehr
flavour tat ein bisschen darauf zieht
doch schönheit schon mal das gute ist
wir haben ja daraus jetzt gleich zwei
portionen und eine weitere bestellt also
bei könnte was für dich dabei
rausspringt geil
wir wollen nicht dass der zug habe
bekommt der knoblauch so stark ist
durchgebraten jetzt gebe ich hier vorne
einmal gas in unserer fahne wo der
saison noch gerade drin war
da machen wir unsere soße 100 milliliter
wasser dazu geben wir den sack von 27
spalten solche werke auf dem müll so
mitten auf die fahrfläche die ganze zeit
mache ich jetzt mal hier und so teriyaki
soße auf schüttet die auch dazu das gar
nicht so wenig hertens butter kommt auch
dazu ich muss wirklich sagen mach doch
ich habe so was noch nie gekocht das
jetzt auch für mich komplett neues ohne
ball habe ich das nie gemacht immer
schiss vor dem reiss muss ich ganz
ehrlich sagen da bin ich sehr gespannt
wie er sein wird so wir müssen jetzt
eben unseres reacher sauce mit der mario
zusammen so leute ist klingelt die
bestellung ist als erstes da freddy
nimmt die bestellung an ich mache hier
schnell
letzte handgriffe anscheinend wird das
hier
kopf an kopf rennen zu zum ende hin zu
roger das ist auch klar ob privat oder
mario ist jetzt auch fertig war
ich würde sagen die platten das ganze
und dann sehen wir uns gleich zum
vergleich also dann treffe ich muss mich
sagen ich bin auch stolz haben mich
nicht wie es angerichtet haben ist
hübsch oder ist unfassbar aber man kennt
das von dir du bist einer der besten
gastgeber dieses capello max 50 das ist
finde so ist wir haben einmal eine harte
nuss bedrohte reaktor war ja die ratsche
mario barth schweinau muss man langsam
machen walter may will diesen spargel
unbedingt deswegen muss ich mir den
langsam das dann noch mal und bin sehr
positiv überrascht über insgesamt von
ganzen gericht hin aber vom reis weil
ich hatte angst vor dem reis und der
schwierigkeit geworden da ist wirklich
selbst weil er fühlt sich nicht so nach
selbstgemachten kopf heute reist ist
kalt und danach fühlt man sich auch
gesund sie den hasen hier mal probiert
punkte jetzt wird es für mich zeit in
die bestellte bowler einzudecken crash
mit dem cording die handel und so er das
ist so zitronen und so war die methode
der bestellte haase erstmal muss gemacht
aus der avocado schon leicht braun
also war es jetzt eine minute vielleicht
langsamer weil du noch schöner anrichten
wollten muss man noch mal dazu sagen
durch können jetzt mal hier ist auch
sehr krank muss man sagen aber man merkt
wirklich dass das fleisch ist merkt man
die bauern ihren solchen leiden immer
die bauzeit zusammen aus vorgeschnitten
sachen und dass das wirklich on point zu
breit ist macht einen unterschied
natürlich dafür haben wir das einfach
bestellt aber das wird jetzt für zwölf
euro gekostet und das hätte mit dem
rabattcode 150 2 euro 15 gekostet aber
auch generell ist es halt geil wenn du
was selber machen kannst ja einfach in
der küche war ich meine das ist auch mal
ein bisschen da kann man seine zeit mal
sinnvoll nutzen mal ein bisschen die
skills upgraden machen vielleicht auch
schwierigere boxen nehmen weil
vielleicht auch irgendwie sich mal eben
nicht mehr schnelle sachen wagen und
auch mehrere alles in allem vollkommen
für sehr zufrieden und sehr frech wie
gesagt einfach ausprobieren und schauen
auch freddys video an
da haben wir einen burger bestellt und
zubereitet beziehungsweise a team
zubereitet freue mich auf den weg und
wir sehen ob sich
du hast gewonnen' schutz gestellt
einfach so